bisingen veränderung dass du eine
emotion und das gefühl dass ich mache
mache ich also wenigstens noch an und
uwe wie liegende paar gegeben haben das
alles und italien brach ein sänger legt
sein inneres frei auch ein weltstar wie
dieter meier gerade mit dem echo preis
für sein lebenswerk ausgezeichnet
exponiert sich hier auf eine ganz neue
art
mp
lang hat er gewartet bis er sich mit
eigenen songs für ein publikum traute
offensichtlich kein einfacher schritt
vorstellen das nicht gemacht das was das
ist erstmal steht textquelle da musst du
dich montieren tombstone treffen da
musste ich in der sonne schien irgendwie
wohl fühlen
das ist für jede mensch wo das zum
ersten mal macht ist das gros
herausfordern
das war bislang sein markenzeichen
aber das höchst erfolgreiche elektronik
duo yello gibt bis heute keine konzerte
und meyers rolle ist eine ganz andere
ein unendliches spielen mit der
studiotechnik und verschiedenen
identitäten
dabei werden die figuren der klangbilder
auftaucht einen erwische ausspielen sich
stelle jemand da
seine persönliche seite liebt dieter
meier nun im projekt autofans aus
der gesang rauchig tiefe sodass in die
musikpresse mit großem charakter stimmen
wie tom waits oder leonard cohen
vergleicht vielleicht etwas gar hoch
gegriffen
und große melodie bürger sein wirst du
verrückt mit juliane koren mit dem tom
waits oder so aber das sind ja ausliegt
und ich sehe ganz sicher richtig und mir
etwas mit dem begriff nötig mehr absolut
gut
lassen wir die vergleiche was hat uns
der chance von meyer zu erzählen er
fabuliert von liebestollen männern die
dem sog der gefühle erliegen und dabei
ihre spur verlieren
süffige melodien mit viel pathos
vorgetragen von einem er trotz seiner
erfolge noch zweifel am leben formuliert
auch mit 69 kann man sich selbst auch
überraschend war für mich klar dass enge
und dass ich für mich ein großes land
ist sie höchst private subjektiv dass
ich wieder stehen offensichtlich
geschichte zählen
doch insgesamt vermag auch das trendige
soundgewand nicht zu kaschieren dass der
auftritt etwas gleichförmig wirkt hat er
da keine bedenken seinen kultstatus zu
verlieren
das hast du eigentlich nur wenn du wie
viele leute immer radikaler
opportunismus vor dem fall habe ich mich
selber gefunden und erfunden und welch
großes glück und das panini immer
irgendwie seitlichen totaler sein und
als ob die ganze gibt's gar kein absturz
auch in seiner neuen single erzählt er
von einem der immer wieder aufstellt und
singend weitergeht wenn auch nicht ganz
autobiografisch so doch sehr nah an
meyers lebensphilosophie